Tasha: 是不都扔了
Tasha: Did you throw everything away?
Jake:耶你气的
Jake: Yay, you're mad.
Jake:你眼镜呢我靠
Jake: Where are your glasses? Oh my god.
Jake:卖买瓜丢了个眼镜
Jake: You lost your glasses while buying melons.
Jake:1234
Jake: 1, 2, 3, 4
Jake:咱把插线板都都给拔了吧
Jake: Let's unplug all the power strips.
Shure: 然后打车票子啥的你就留好
Shure: And keep your taxi receipts and stuff.
Shure: 到时候跟那个小畅报
Shure: You can report them to Xiao Chang later.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 真的呀
Shure: Yes, really.
Shure: 你看那不还有碘伏呢吗
Shure: See, there's still iodine.
Shure: 然后涂完碘伏然后把耳耳朵夹在里面
Shure: After applying the iodine, clip your ear in.
Shure: 然后一摁
Shure: Then press it.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 对啊就穿过去了
Shure: Yeah, it goes right through.
Shure: 没想到吧
Shure: Surprised?
Jake:哼哼确实没想到哼
Jake: Hmm, didn't expect that, huh?
Jake:确实很难想这个
Jake: It's really hard to imagine this.
Tasha: 我真的想打个耳洞
Tasha: I really want to get my ears pierced.
Shure: 试试
Shure: Try it.
Shure: 是不是差点就信了
Shure: Almost believed it, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Shure: 怎么样怎么样这个
Shure: How about this?
Shure: 骗人的本领
Shure: My talent for lying.
Shure: 撒谎不眨眼
Shure: Lying without blinking.
Lucia: 气死
Lucia: So annoying.
Tasha: 甩了他他不专心
Tasha: Dump him, he's not paying attention.
Jake:哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Alice:刚看到消息
Alice: Just saw the message.
Shure: 得得得得得得我的心
Shure: My heart...
Alice:这有用吗这还
Alice: Is this useful at all?
Alice:这坨东西还有用吗
Alice: Is this thing still useful?
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 很有用
Shure: Very useful.
Alice:搁哪
Alice: Where to put it?
Shure: 这几个是谢彬竹的那个我靠
Shure: These few are for Xie Binzhu, damn.
Shure: 还有一个应该
Shure: There should be one more.
Alice:那要不你给他收起来
Alice: Then why don't you put it away for him?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 这四个是谢彬竹的
Shure: These four are Xie Binzhu's.
Shure: 这个是杨老板
Shure: This one is Jake's.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 杨老板这个是什么的
Shure: Jake, what is this for?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:这一层就5个
Jake: There are only five on this level.
Alice:这是不是搬下去啊
Alice: Should we move this down?
Alice:这个木凳子
Alice: This wooden bench.
Shure: 这也说不用
Shure: They said they don't need it.
Shure: 搬下去就放这了
Shure: Just move it down and place it here.
Shure: 哎呀音箱把拔下
Shure: Oh no, unplug the speaker.
Shure: 哎音响已经拔了
Shure: Oh, the speaker is already unplugged.
Shure: 音响我想直接寄回家了
Shure: I think I'll just send the speaker back home.
Shure: 反正我在学校应该也用不到了吧
Shure: Anyway, I probably won't need it at school.
Shure: 这其实监听一下应该也没有什么用
Shure: Monitoring it here doesn't seem to have any use.
Alice:西瓜什么时候买的
Alice: When did you buy the watermelon?
其他人：刚刚
Others: Just now.
Alice:刚刚
Alice: Just now.
其他人：我们俩刚刚出去了一下
Others: We just went out for a bit.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Shure: 因为没买到刮刮乐
Shure: Because we couldn't buy scratch cards.
Shure: 所以就给大家买个刮
Shure: So we bought a watermelon for everyone.
Alice:哈哈哈好谢谢
Alice: Hahaha, thanks.
Shure: 但是我买的这个盒子我已经找不到了
Shure: But I can't find the box I bought.
Shure: 我总不能背着他背回去吧
Shure: I can't carry it back, can I?
Katrina: 我总不能背着他背回去吧
Katrina: I can't carry it back, can I?
其他人：嗯你要是
Others: Hmm, if you...
Shure: 我不会的哈哈
Shure: I won't, haha.
其他人：不是我是说你要是从学校去的话
Others: No, I mean, if you go from school...
其他人：我那倒是有盒子还有泡沫纸
Others: I have a box and foam paper.
Shure: 行从你那薅薅吧
Shure: Okay, I'll take some from you.
Shure: 哎这应该也不缺什么泡沫纸
Shure: Hey, we shouldn't be short of foam paper.
Shure: 盒子什么的东西
Shure: And boxes and stuff.
Shure: 你好聪明
Shure: You're so smart.
Shure: 你又做那个青蛙脸干什么
Shure: Why are you making that frog face again?
Shure: 帮我帮我
Shure: Help me, help me.
Shure: 低了一下这个尾巴
Shure: Lower this tail a bit.
Tasha: 好像没什么要忙的了
Tasha: Seems like there's nothing much left to do.
Alice:啊啊
Alice: Ah, ah.
Tasha: 我说好像没什么要忙的了
Tasha: I said it seems like there's nothing much left to do.
Shure: 我们就下去吧
Shure: Let's just go down.
Shure: 被他拽折了
Shure: He pulled it and broke it.
Jake:这个地为什么会这样呢
Jake: Why is the floor like this?
Lucia: 可能有饮料之类东西然后他有糖就
Lucia: Maybe there was some drink or something, and it had sugar...
Jake:嗯一地的糖
Jake: Hmm, a floor full of sugar.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Done.
Lucia: 现在他的整齐程度就和昨天一模一样
Lucia: Now it's as tidy as it was yesterday.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Hmm, good.
Lucia: 我现我现在是不是要到外面
Lucia: Should I go outside now?
Jake:呃还没
Jake: Uh, not yet.
Lucia: 还是
Lucia: Or...
Jake:还有几个人
Jake: There are still a few people.
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then.
Jake:呵呵对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:等人齐了一起走
Jake: We'll leave together when everyone's here.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 那就把别的东西整理整理
Lucia: Then I'll organize the other stuff.
Lucia: 哦这我昨天那个那个啥放这吧
Lucia: Oh, I'll put this thing I had yesterday here.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 他还可以出镜一下
Lucia: It can still be on camera.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 我下去把门口整理一下
Lucia: I'll go tidy up the entrance.
Katrina: 可以扫吗
Katrina: Can you sweep?
Katrina: 可以先扫我的吗
Katrina: Can you sweep mine first?
Katrina: 因为我有点想睡觉
Katrina: Because I'm feeling a bit sleepy.
Jake:想睡觉
Jake: Sleepy?
Katrina: 我有点不舒服
Katrina: I'm not feeling well.
Jake:好的行呃
Jake: Okay, sure, uh...
Lucia: 这个是不可以扔掉的
Lucia: This can't be thrown away.
Lucia: 这好像也是我昨天的墙贴
Lucia: This seems to be my wall sticker from yesterday.
Lucia: 这是效果示意图
Lucia: It's a sample picture of the effect.
Jake:好哈哈可以
Jake: Okay, haha, that's fine.
Jake:微微准备下去吧
Jake: Tasha, get ready to go down.
Jake:在吗
Jake: Are you there?
Jake:准备下去吧
Jake: Get ready to go down.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Jake:走走走
Jake: Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Katrina: 哈喽
Katrina: Hello.
Katrina: 辛苦了
Katrina: Thanks for the hard work.
Katrina: 我把这个端进去
Katrina: I'll take this inside.
Jake:你也可以在房间里面坐着
Jake: You can also sit in the room.
Jake:但是不能动
Jake: But you can't move.
Jake:你作为房间里面的一个
Jake: You'll be part of the room.
Katrina: 为什么
Katrina: Why?
Katrina: 啊啊
Katrina: Ahh.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 没事你先扫吧我再
Katrina: It's okay, you sweep first, I'll...
其他人：狗拿过
Others: The dog took it.
Jake:哎呀不好意思你在那边哎
Jake: Oh, sorry, you were over there.
Jake:对对对狗狗我放门口
Jake: Yeah, yeah, I'll put the dog at the door.
Shure: 在干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
Katrina: 我在镇定自己
Katrina: I'm calming myself down.
Katrina: 我有点想吐
Katrina: I feel like throwing up.
Shure: 太不好了整个人
Shure: That's really bad.
Shure: 今天要把这个房子拆成什么样
Shure: How much do we need to demolish this house today?
Shure: 就是完全恢复原样
Shure: Like, fully restore it to its original state?
Jake:啥啥啥啥啥
Jake: What, what, what?
Shure: 我说我们今天要把这房子拆成什么样
Shure: I said, how much do we need to demolish this house today?
Jake:拆成原样
Jake: Restore it to its original state.
Shure: 那那
Shure: Well, um...
Jake:你你拿的时候记得啥样不
Jake: Do you remember how it looked when you took it?
Shure: 那个什么go Pro的时候也拆
Shure: When we took the GoPro, do we also dismantle it?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:那当然得拆
Jake: Of course, we have to dismantle it.
Shure: 今天都拆了是吗
Shure: We're dismantling everything today, right?
Jake:今晚都拆
Jake: Yes, dismantle everything tonight.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: （歌词）晚风吹呀吹
Shure: (singing lyrics) The evening breeze blows...
Shure: 把我这个衣服拿过来
Shure: Pass me that shirt.
Jake:对我这电脑也要全拆了
Jake: Yeah, we need to dismantle this computer too.
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow.
Jake:哦呦
Jake: Oh my.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake:我这电脑还得全
Jake: I need to dismantle this computer.
Jake:也得全拆了
Jake: It has to be completely taken apart.
Jake:回头你们还能打把麻将
Jake: Later, you guys can play some mahjong.
Shure: 哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh, oh!
Jake:开心了不
Jake: Are you happy now?
Shure: 快快拆
Shure: Hurry, hurry and dismantle it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha!
Shure: 我觉得杨老板这屋拆的刻不容缓
Shure: I think Jake's room needs to be dismantled urgently.
Shure: 因为他一直压着那麻将机
Shure: Because he's been covering the mahjong table.
Lucia: 这就是你一直没能打上的原因是吧
Lucia: So that's why you haven't been able to play?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:对等了一周了
Jake: Yeah, been waiting for a week.
Jake:可算能打上了
Jake: Finally, we can play.
Jake:呵垂涎三尺
Jake: I'm drooling over it.
Lucia: 哎呀这就剩一个了
Lucia: Oh, there's only one left.
Lucia: 我给大家收拾收拾
Lucia: Let me clean up for everyone.
Lucia: 尾声呵呵呵
Lucia: The finale, hahaha.
Jake:对是是一个麻将的尾声
Jake: Yeah, it's the end of a mahjong game.
Jake:然后谁谁赢先谁先走
Jake: Then whoever wins first can leave first.
Jake:呵呵谁赢谁先走
Jake: Haha, whoever wins can leave first.
Lucia: 什么什么
Lucia: What, what?
Lucia: 谁谁谁谁
Lucia: Who, who, who?
Jake:谁先胡谁先胡谁先走
Jake: Whoever wins first can leave first.
Jake:不胡不准走
Jake: No winning, no leaving.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 不扶不准走
Lucia: No winning, no leaving.
Lucia: 妈呀
Lucia: Oh my.
Lucia: 那我
Lucia: Then I...
Shure: 锁好门我要胡把大的
Shure: Lock the door, I want to win big.
Lucia: 那我这种不会打的岂不是走不了了
Lucia: Then if I can't play, I can't leave?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：没事大家都走了就只剩你了
Others: Don't worry, when everyone else leaves, you'll be the only one left.
Jake:没一个
Jake: Not one.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：你就可以走
Others: Then you can leave.
Lucia: 就没有人管我了是吗
Lucia: So no one will care about me?
Lucia: 不行那这房间至少要剩下4个人
Lucia: No, at least four people should stay in this room.
Lucia: 因为当只剩3个人时候就没法打了
Lucia: Because if there are only three people left, we can't play.
Shure: 哎我找一个袋子
Shure: Hey, let me find a bag.
Shure: 还剩不剩
Shure: Is there any left?
Shure: 什么盒马的袋子了咱们这
Shure: Any Hema bags left here?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Lucia: 那是我的裤子吗
Lucia: Are those my pants?
Lucia: 这么长时间还没洗完吗
Lucia: Have they not finished washing yet?
Jake:你的半个小时挺长
Jake: Your "half an hour" is quite long.
Shure: 我要装那些东西
Shure: I need to pack those things.
Lucia: 哦竟然不是
Lucia: Oh, turns out it's not.
Lucia: 是哪位好心人已经帮我把裤子挂上了
Lucia: Who's the kind person that hung my pants?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Katrina: 我呵呵没事
Katrina: Oh, it's nothing.
Lucia: 哦谢谢你
Lucia: Oh, thank you.
Katrina: 因为我急着洗
Katrina: I was in a hurry to wash.
Lucia: 我就说他应该好了
Lucia: I thought it should be done by now.
Lucia: 没洗这么久
Lucia: Didn't take that long to wash.
其他人：感觉像什么单位
Others: Feels like some kind of workplace.
其他人：团建的那种
Others: Like a team-building event.
其他人： 妈呀
Others: Oh my
Jake:嚯这是要跳舞这是
Jake: Whoa, are we going to dance?
其他人：哈哈是吧
Others: Haha, right?
其他人：我也觉得
Others: I think so too.
其他人：他这衣服好好看啊这是
Others: This outfit looks so good.
Jake:上广场这是
Jake: Heading to the square, huh?
其他人：你看正常人哪会买这种衣服啊少爷
Others: Look, what normal person would buy clothes like this, young master?
Shure: 我妈买的
Shure: My mom bought it.
其他人：奶奶哈
Others: Grandma, huh?
Shure: 哈哈哈少什么奶奶
Shure: Hahaha, what grandma?
Shure: 哈哈哈那叫老夫人
Shure: Haha, we call her madam.
其他人：哈
Others: Haha
Lucia: 哎呀
Lucia: Oh dear
Lucia: 这玩意怎么回事
Lucia: What's up with this thing?
Lucia: 该换个地方放
Lucia: Should put it somewhere else.
Shure: 他还有电居然
Shure: It still has power, surprisingly.
Shure: 主要我的塞尔达是数字版
Shure: Mainly because my Zelda is a digital version.
Shure: 所以马寄回来也没有用其实
Shure: So even if it gets mailed back, it's useless.
Shure: 看你就很好会问我存没存
Shure: See, you know to ask if I saved it.
Shure: 我妹直接给我关了
Shure: My sister just turned it off.
Shure: 气死我了
Shure: It pissed me off.
Shure: 我还不是
Shure: I wasn't even
Shure: 上次不是塞尔达
Shure: Last time it wasn't Zelda.
Shure: 是我玩动森
Shure: It was me playing Animal Crossing.
Shure: 我在这修了一下午的那那什么家呀
Shure: I spent the whole afternoon building houses.
Shure: 墙啊桥结果我妹没给
Shure: Walls, bridges and in the end, my sister didn't save it.
Shure: 我保存直接给我退了
Shure: When I saved, it just quit on me.
Jake:好啊动森
Jake: Oh, Animal Crossing.
Jake:疫情那会躺床上玩是吧
Jake: During the pandemic, you played it lying in bed, right?
Jake:疫情刚开始那会是
Jake: When the pandemic just started.
Shure: 谁知道啊
Shure: Who knows.
Shure: 有些为什么
Shure: Some things, why...
Shure: 跟我熟人
Shure: with my friends...
Shure: 他就给我带了一件白t四件外套
Shure: He brought me a white t-shirt and four jackets.
Shure: 哈哈哈真是正常人类能带过来了
Shure: Hahaha, can a normal person bring these?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Lucia: 我可不可以认领一下这个箱子
Lucia: Can I claim this box?
Jake:我要开始扫了可以了吗
Jake: I'm going to start sweeping, okay?
Shure: type也不能冲下
Shure: Type can't flush down.
Shure: 这个这个有个啾啾哎对
Shure: This, this has a "joo joo" sound, right.
Alice:啊给我粘胶带
Alice: Ah, give me the tape.
Alice:开始扫了
Alice: Start sweeping.
Alice:干嘛呢你当虫呢
Alice: What are you doing, pretending to be a bug?
Alice:能给我粘牢固点吗
Alice: Can you stick it more firmly?
Alice:这胶随便使
Alice: Use the tape freely.
Alice:给谢谢我躺会啊胶
Alice: Thanks, I'll lie down for a bit, tape.
Alice:那当然
Alice: Of course.
Alice:那结实不给墙皮粘掉了还得赔钱呢
Alice: If it's not firm and the wall paint comes off, we'll have to pay.
Alice:谢谢你小姐姐
Alice: Thank you, Miss.
Alice:小姐姐你对我真好
Alice: Miss, you're so good to me.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Alice:加油刘婷加油
Alice: Go, Liu Ting, go!
Alice:刘婷加啊
Alice: Liu Ting, keep going.
其他人：我给你撕了信不信
Others: I'll tear it off for you, believe it or not.
Alice:你对我好点好吗
Alice: Treat me better, okay?
Alice:你得心疼一下我好吗
Alice: You need to care about me a bit, okay?
Alice:好的
Alice: Alright.
Alice:给你加点音乐music
Alice: Let me add some music, music.
Alice:你可以多沾点好吗
Alice: Can you stick more?
其他人：你确保他录的时候他不能掉
Others: Make sure it doesn't fall off while recording.
其他人：要不然我们就白干
Others: Otherwise, all our work is for nothing.
其他人：太厚了太厚了你这外套太厚了
Others: It's too thick, too thick, your jacket is too thick.
Alice:小姐姐你不会够不着吧
Alice: Hey girl, you won't be able to reach it, right?
其他人：说什么呢你
Others: What are you talking about?
Shure: 那那个不是就是没有什么缓冲的吗
Shure: So, there's no buffer, right?
Shure: 好侧边的话我拉着应该也没问题
Shure: Alright, if I pull from the side, it should be fine.
Shure: 没事问题都不大
Shure: No worries, it's not a big deal.
Shure: 反正400块钱而已
Shure: Anyway, it's just 400 bucks.
Lucia: 这个是谁的啊
Lucia: Whose is this?
Lucia: 行行行好嘞好嘞
Lucia: Alright, alright, got it.
Lucia: 我放这就行
Lucia: I'll just put it here.
Jake:是有人来了吗
Jake: Did someone come?
Lucia: 有一个快递来了
Lucia: A delivery arrived.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:你的店
Jake: Your store.
Jake:别忘了星之卡比
Jake: Don't forget about Kirby Star.
Jake:一会在我来之前要弄完
Jake: You need to finish it before I come back.
Shure: 什么好
Shure: What?
Jake:一会我要扫这边所以
Jake: I need to clean here later, so...
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake:我上面可能扫他个20分钟吧
Jake: I'll probably sweep upstairs for about 20 minutes.
Jake:然后20分钟之后
Jake: And then after 20 minutes...
Jake:你们就要悄悄的跑到二楼去躲着对
Jake: You guys need to quietly sneak up to the second floor and hide, okay?
Alice:多粘点
Alice: Stick more of it.
其他人：尽力吧
Others: Do your best.
Shure: 一袋咖啡豆剃须刀
Shure: A bag of coffee beans and a razor.
Alice:小姐姐你对我真好
Alice: Girl, you're so good to me.
Alice:小姐姐
Alice: Girl.
Jake:上装备开凿
Jake: Gear up and start drilling.
其他人：外套外套外套你穿的了这么多吗
Others: Jacket, jacket, jacket, can you wear so many?
Jake:插管
Jake: Tubes.
Jake:哈哈插一圈管开扫
Jake: Haha, put tubes around and start sweeping.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Girl, you...
Alice:对我真好
Alice: are really good to me.
Alice:我都要
Alice: I want it all.
其他人：你不准
Others: You can't.
Alice:哈哈哈我还没说呢
Alice: Haha, I didn't even say anything yet.
其他人：你不许说
Others: You're not allowed to say.
Alice:我靠我真服了
Alice: Oh man, I'm really impressed.
Alice:这个窗帘真好看刘婷
Alice: These curtains are so pretty, Liu Ting.
其他人：这些能放你包里面吗
Others: Can these fit in your bag?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice:不是床帘
Alice: It's not a bed curtain.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Alice:太有品位了
Alice: So classy.
Shure: 背带就没什么了其实
Shure: The suspenders are nothing, really.
Alice:太有品位了
Alice: So classy.
Alice:这什么水平
Alice: What's this level?
Alice:这是什么
Alice: What is this?
Alice:神马水平
Alice: What kind of level is this?
Alice:请你不要到处
Alice: Please don't...
Shure: 哦我还有睡衣
Shure: Oh, I also have pajamas.
Shure: 还有一个水库
Shure: There's also a reservoir.
Alice:我撕掉了
Alice: I tore it off.
Alice:感觉那已经不中用了
Alice: Felt like it was useless already.
Alice:换新一批
Alice: Time to replace it with a new batch.
Shure: AI懵了这两个人到底是什么关系
Shure: AI is confused, what exactly is the relationship between these two?